in fact I do have a great story about  Andre say it my daughters at the time  were uh three and a half and two and so  I said okay I'm going to I'm going to  England and uh I I'm gonna be and  there's a princess in the movie and I'm  assuming they're gonna go oh really and  nothing and and then uh there's a sword  fight and then there's a giant and as  soon as like the word giant got out of  my lips both of my girls perked up and  they started throwing peppering me with  a question what's a giant like Daddy how  big is he and I realize they have to  meet Andre we go to his trailer his  trailer is as big as a boxcar and we  walk up the steps and turn the corner  and we look down the length of the  makeup trailer and Andre gets up and  suddenly the reality hits my girls and  they start screaming at the top of their  lungs and I go back to apologize to  Andre and I say Andre Andre I'm so sorry  and he said don't worry boss they either  run to me or they'll run away from me